Our world has become pretty much digital,...
...and coding is really the logic of thinking about digital things.
It is absolutely essential that the kids that are born today...
...think that coding is just the most natural thing to do.
The idea with the Root is that we have a single robot...
...that has a really interesting behavior.
It could move on whiteboards and it could draw...
...but what makes it powerful is the different ways in which you could program it.
A young kid understands consequences.
If this, then this will happen.
Now, they get to program the consequences to their robot.
They can think about what a machine is able to do.
What did they tell the robot...
...and how did the robot misinterpret what they said?
That part of our brain that's analytical...
...and that thinks about processes is the one that Root is trying to engage.